サッブパパスアカラナン クサラッソウパサンパダ サチットパリヨダパナン エタン ブッダナサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
で まあ昨日はあの12時半で夜ね
まあまあ2時 2時半になるまでで
もうさっとこのスライド書いてみましたけど
勢いで書いてみたら これちょっと使いづらいと難しいではないかなとね
思いましたが とにかくこれ書いたものを捨てるわけにはいきませんだからね
その通りに行きますけど
まあ難しいことは飛ばしてください
まあできるだけ話をわかりやすくします
テーマは人として生まれたならばということで
景色を台無しにする私たち
いきなり難しい話になりますね
業が創造する命 業は命のそう
命を創造し管理するポテンシャルですね
命を作っているのは業というものなんです
業をバイパスして何かをすることはできません
業は心の基本的なエネルギーです
我々に心というものがありまして
この心は回転しているんです
この回転する燃料が業なんですね
生命はどのように構成するのかは
業の力に決めます そこでこの心
回転するエネルギーによって結果が出ますね
まあ普通単純な話ですよ
例えば心が弱い心 そんなに馬力がない心でね
そうすると まあ燃料もその程度の燃料になるんですね
それで何かしようと思っちゃうと
体命作ろうと思っちゃうと
それなりの弱い命を作るんですよ
まあ車と同じですよ ものすごくもう馬力がある車もあるし
普通の軽自動車もあるしね
だから出せるスピードとかね
走れる距離とかね その持っているエネルギーによって変わりますね
運命を変え変えるために人は他力に他力を頼むが
それは無意味です 人間というのは変な生命体だから
なんかどこかの力で自分を助けてくれると思っているんですね
だから人類の中で この神にお願いする
お祈りするという習慣が
地球上すべての人間が持っているんですね
神様がやってくる それはもう真理を知らないからなんです
やってくれません 何も
運命を変えたければ 自分の心と業に頼むことです
頼むことですよ 自分自身の運命を変えたければ
計画通りに生きてみたければできます
自分の心を調べて これ機械だから
エンジンだからね このエンジンの燃料のキャパシティと馬力をね
それを上げるだけなんです
だから自分でできるんです
これはもう 100年ぐらい前
イギリスでね あるちっちゃな本ができちゃってね
あの そんな小さい本ですけど
これものすごく世界中使っていた本で
名前は AS THE MAN THINKETH なんですね
あれが古い英語なんですね
だから AS THE MAN THINKETH という風に書いてあったんだけど
このすべてあなたの思考次第ということで
彼がこのダンマパダの第1 2 偈でインスピレーションを受けて
思考と運命はどのように変わるのかということをちっちゃな本を書いて
それから結構活動していたんですが
だからこの 私はこれ 現代的にこの単語を変えてね
あの あなたはどんな人間になるのかということは
あなたの思考次第ですよと
ということは 自分の運命は自分好きなように自分に変えられる
だからこの操縦桿が自分を持っていて
それ使ってくださいなんです
自分で操縦しないで お願いします
何とかしてください これ
ローラーコースターに入れているわけじゃないので
人生は他人任せでローラーコースターに乗ったらそういうことでしょう
泣き叫ぶだけ そうじゃないんです
自分が運転席に座っているんです
だから運転できんだったら
泣くんじゃなくて 運転の技術を学べばいいでしょう
だって誰が誰もこれ運転しませんだから
自分という乗り物に だから仏教はその運転技術を教えているんです
そういうことで 好きなように生きられますよ
はい そこまで もうすごい省略してさっさと飛ばしましょう
で 命の能力リミット だから今乗り物の例えを出したでしょ？乗り物になっちゃうと
なんか能力制限されてますね
でもそれは全然問題ないでしょうに
例えば道路で運転したいからといって
ジェットジャンボジェット機で運転できんでしょうに
道路で運転するならば
普通の車に乗らなくちゃいけない
それ自分が大量の荷物も運んでいるならば
車ではダメですね でっかいトラックを使わなくちゃいけない
しかし ハワイまで行きたかったら
自分のトラックでは行けませんね
そうすると乗り換えて
飛行機に乗り換えてハワイまで飛ばなくちゃいかんでしょうに
そうやって乗り乗り物を入れ替えればいいんです
輪廻転生というのはそういうもので
乗り物を入れ替えるような世界なんですね
それで ハワイに行きたいなと
1週間  2週間遊びたいなと思っても 5
万しか持ってない人にはできないでしょ
ハワイ旅行は 5万しか持ってないんだったら
そこら辺の小田急線に乗ってどこでしたっけ？箱根に行って帰ってくださいと
それでもギリギリやと
しかし  50万円持っているならばね
まあハワイ旅行は無理じゃないんですね
会社に頼むな 自分でチケットを買っていくならばね
無理じゃないんです ですから
輪廻転生するときは 自分の希望はどうあろうとも
持っている財産によってね
だって誰だって死後 ものすごい永遠に天国になりたいと思ってるでしょ？諦めてください
これどれぐらい財産を持ってるのかっていうことで
それも業なんですよ 決めなくちゃいけないんですね
ハワイに行きたいんだけど
箱根で終わらなくちゃいけない羽目になると
誰にも文句言う必要ないんです
誰のせいでもない 自分持っている力によってそれは決めますね
そういうわけで 命にいつでも能力リミットがあるんです
すべての生命にできることもできないこともあります
だって私たちにも音は聞けますけど
コウモリには敵わないね
私たちも匂いは嗅ぎますけど
犬には敵わないね そういうことよ
いろいろリミットがあるんです
コウモリはもうすごい耳が優れてね
ものすごい発達しているんです
音で世界を見ているんだから
しかし こんにちはと言える
コウモリはキーと言うかもしれませんだけどね
これできん だからコウモリできないこともあるし
我々にできることもあるし
我々にできないこともあるし
コウモリにできることもあるんですよ
種の間では リミットは明確で
種の間っていうのは 今
コウモリと人間例えたでしょ
2種類ですね 人間と犬とかね
あるいは犬とコウモリ
犬と猫 そうやって種別で調べてみると
リミットがあるということははっきりわかるでしょ
皆様 犬と猫 両方飼っているとしましょう
同じ能力じゃないね 犬にできることが猫にできないし
猫にできることは犬にできない
同じ食べ物を食べているのに
同じ人に飼われているのに
種が違うんですね 畜生の生命を観察すると簡単にわかります
業に与えられた能力の範囲で生命は生きているのです
だから我々には この業が
この乗り物 体という乗り物を作ってくれたんですね
その与えられた能力範囲で生活しなくちゃいけない
我々人間という乗り物になったんだけど
空を飛べませんね カラスという乗り物に乗った生命は空を飛んでいく
羨ましがったって意味がないんだ
日本人でいるんですよ
生まれ変わったら猫になりたいとかね
そうっと失敗したでしょうね
人生は あれ 怠け者ですよ
疲れてるんで 生きていて
まあそれはみんな冗談で思うことだから
本気じゃないと思いますけどね
まあ冗談で言うのは全然構いませんだけどね
これより犬になった方がマシやとかね
まあ本気にしないでください
だから 例えば地球上で猫も生活している
我々も生活している 自分たちのゴータミー僧侶だったら猫 3匹いるんだけど
限界できてますよ そっちには我々も生きているもいるんだけど
能力違いますよ 私達にできることは何一つもあの猫 3匹にできません
猫 3匹やることが我々にできません
それで何か問題あるかと
全然ないんです お互いに嫉妬しない方がいいでしょ
意味がないでしょ そういうことで
我々は与えられた業に与えられたリミット
能力 リミットの範囲で生きているんですね
しかし この能力を少々育てると
結構楽しいんです 例えば猫も何かこちらから教えて
教えて 何かちっぽけな芸なんか学んだらね
これはすごい面白くなっちゃうんです
お互い様に 大体犬なんかにはね
バーンと言ったらドカーンと転がってくるならば
死んだふりをしてくれるならばね
これは超楽しいんですよ
猫は犬も楽しいんです
ああ 喜んでくれたとかね
ことだから自分に与え
だから犬にはその程度しかできないを手と言ったら手を出すこととかね
何もわかってないんで
とにかく手じゃなくあれ
足ですけどね 手と言ったら足を出してくれるしね
お座り言ったら それはちゃんと座りますしね
で 犬にはその程度の能力
ちょっとだけ育てることはできる
でも 犬と一緒に生活している我々にとっては
それからすごい楽しみが起きてきますね
だから犬だけじゃなくて
我々もね 自分に生まれつき与えられた能力をちょっとちょっと育てた方がいいんじゃない
地獄餓鬼畜生人間神々梵天
生命の次元の話に入ります
そこでこの仏教は人間に喋ってるんだけど
仏教の理論は生命というスタンスで語ってるんですね
生命に関わる真理 すべての生命
だから生命といえば何かといったら
だいたいこの 6種類ですね
6種類のことを 考えているんです
次元の違う生命の間でコミュニケーションはできません
はい 我々は畜生という次元を知っていますね
人間以外の地球に住んでいる生命は
畜生というグループに入るんですね
微生物からクジラとゾウさんまで
だから同じ次元でしょ
畜生という次元なんですね
あの畜生って 皆様 日本語で使っているこの怒りの言葉じゃないんです
これは普通専門用語なんです
アニマルキングダムなんです
英語ではね だから畜生もという同じ次元ですが
ゾウさんとクジラさん
一番巨体の生命でしょ？お互い会話できる？できない
互いの気持ち通じ合うことできる？できませんね
それは同じ次元で だから我々人間という次元でしょ
私たちは犬を何考えているかさっぱりわからないんですよ
一応推測はしますが 長い間一緒に生活したんだから
まあ長い間ですからね
まあある程度で知っている錯覚はしますね
本当のところはそうじゃなくて
人間に依存しなきゃ犬は幸福にならないんですね
だから人間に依存しているんですね
人間も犬がついてくるともうすごく楽しいんです
なんか生きてるとなんかつまらないしね
退屈でしょうしね それで言うことを聞いてくれない犬を飼ってみたら
結構なんか楽しくなっちゃうんですね
ですから この お互い理解しているかどうかってよくわかりませんだけど
私はこの私は渋谷区のね
シアラにいますけど そこらへんみんな犬を飼っているんですね
私はこのセットで観察するんです
飼い主と犬 ワンセットで
そこで見えるのは この飼い主が犬の奴隷のように使用人のように面倒を見てあげたりする
しかし 犬は全然関係なく自分の世界で生きている
飼い主が男性の場合は
犬はちらちらとこそっとその人の顔を見るんです
顔を見て 自分の性格をそれに合わせて直せるんです
結局 犬に犬に読まれてるんじゃない？あなたをと言いたくなるんですね
だから犬の散歩をする男性たちは
偉そうに犬を持ってなんか偉い誇らしげに行くんだけど
だって自分の希望通り犬が
するんだからね 逆なのね
本当は 犬はいつでもこれ気が付かないんですよ
ちょっと人が別の方を見る瞬間で顔を見てうん
知らん こうそれで読み取ってるんです
でも気持ちはもうわかってるんです
散歩する人が女性だったら
まあ犬ははっきりとわがままを言うんですね
だから結構戦いになります
犬が言う通りに散歩をしてあげている女性がもう変えなく
自分考えを変えなくちゃあかんですね
だからそこを見てみると
男性が犬を散歩する 女性が犬を散歩すると
そこそこ別々な世界が現れてきますね
私はどちらかというと
犬がわがまま言っている方がいいと思ってますから
だから犬がそこを自由感じちゃうでしょ
散歩にこの道路で行きたくないとは女性が思ったっても
犬が無理やりそちらに引っ張っちゃうんですね
引っ張っちゃうと もう仕方がなくそちらに行かなくちゃいけないんですね
男性の場合はそれはしません
顔を見て はいはい こちらですと
犬は先に考えているんです
ある日 そんなに足が速くない女性がね
犬を散歩しているのを見てね
甲州街道なんでしたけど
あそこで犬がのんびり歩くんですね
もう だから女性の足の力に合わせてるんです
それで甲州街道 幅が広いでしょうね
それで赤信号のところで二人とも待って待ってるんですね
待って 信号変わったら
この犬は勢いであの女性を引っ張っているんで
引っ張り勢いで向こうまで行くんですね
それ見たら犬の方が賢いじゃないかなと
だってあんなスピードで道路渡る
途中で赤くなるんだからね
犬はそれ知っていて もう早く渡った方が身の安全だと
あのおばあさんを引っ張っちゃって向こうに行くんですね
はい そういうことで いろいろ観察してみてください
面白いんです 世界はね
なので今日のポイントは
この次元違うの生命の間ではコミュニケーションは成り立たない
人間は畜生がいることだけ知っていますが
互いに 話し合ったり どういうか平仮名になった方がいいのに
自分が書いたんだから理解し合ったりすることはできません
まあ自分あの慌てて急がったからちょっと漢字入ってますけどね
まあ意味はわかるでしょうね
我々は畜生がいることを知ってますよ
が 会話できません 例えば猿とかね
チンパンジーとか 人間飼っているでしょうにね
動物園とかね ものすごく苦労してますよね
お互いコミュニケーションしようということで
うまくは成り立たないんですね
同時に神々は人間がいることを知っているでしょう
では 上の次元 神々というね
もしかすると我々は畜生のことを知っているように
神々は人間という種類も種もいるんだよと知っているかも
しかし コミュニケーションは取れないでしょ？対話したことがありますか？神々とあるというならば
頭を調べてください 何かおかしいんです
私はここで言いたいのはね
神にお願いしたってもね
向こうは理解しないんです
はい 次に行きます 次元分類の仕方
なんで仏教がそうやって次元分類したのかと
仏教は学問的で科学的に分類するんだから
それなりの理由があって
この次元分類しているんですね
生きている上で苦楽 幸福
不楽を感じます あの皆様の知識と違って
仏教で見る命っていうのは
命っていうのはある精神組織があって
物質組織があって この組織が互いに依存して苦楽
幸福 不楽を感じるんです
ただそれだけなんです
命の基本的な定義は 精神というエネルギーの流れがある
物質という流れがある
物質はいろいろ組織できているんですね
精神も一つの組織なんですね
お互いに活動するんですね
例えば車 いくら精密にできても
人間が入らなきゃ動かないでしょ
この 2つの組織の組み合わせで運転という現象が現れるんです
車が動くという現象が現れるんです
車が動くということを起こすためには
よくできた車という組織と入り込んだ人間という組織
2つが必要です だからこの体
物質なんですけど 明らかに物質ですが
物質は自然の物質と違って複雑に組み合わさっているんですね
それから組織ができているんですね
でも一人で動かないんです
動けるようにすべて準備はできている
そこで感覚が入り込んで動かしちゃうんですね
感覚とは空楽 不空 不楽という三つなんですね
それが命の基本的な定義
この感覚から生きるために必要な衝動が起きます
そこで生きるためのエネルギーが必要なんですね
そのエネルギーがこの感覚から作るんです
空楽 不空 不楽でエネルギーが生まれるんです
それで回転するんです
寿命もそれに従って変わります
だからまあ 寿命も苦 この感覚の変化と物質の関係で成り立つんですね
はい それで地獄っていうのは
地獄は極端に苦のみを感じる次元です
あの地獄の中でもたくさん
次元がありますよ だって畜生の中でもそうです
鳥たち 魚たち あの普通獣たちね
4本の足で走る獣たち
それから足がないんだけど
蛇とかね お腹で動く いろんな次元がありますよ
それぞれすごく違いますね
それで地獄も仏典によると八種類あるんだそうですね
大きな次元がね それから一つの地獄には
またあの つなげている小さな地獄
また 108 かなんかあるみたいですね
だからいろんな地獄があるんですね
それで だから八の地獄に合わせている
またまあ 百ぐらい十ある地獄あると言ったらすごい数でしょうね
だからその中にいる生命もそれぞれ互い違います
その分け方が このどのような
どんなタイプの苦しみ
受けるかっていうことなんです
地獄で生まれたら苦しみを感じないと生きられないんです
苦しみがないと もし地獄の生命が長い間苦しんで苦しんで
何か苦しみを感じなくなっちゃうと
そうするとそこで死んじゃうんです
死んじゃって 別なところに生まれ変わっちゃう
苦しみの強弱によって
地獄にもいくつかの次元があります
餓鬼道の苦しみは地獄ほど強くないが
楽はない 餓鬼道という
また膨大な種類の次元がありまして
それである程度で仏典では説明していますよ
こんなタイプの餓鬼 こんなタイプの餓鬼とかね
だからそれぞれ感じる苦しみの仕方が違います
でも地獄ほど極端ではないんですね
畜生の場合は苦しみは餓鬼道より弱い
動物たちはやっぱり主に苦しみを感じていますけど
でもまあそんなに大した苦しみでもないんですね
よくあるのは 動物世界で恐怖感の苦しみなんですね
ずっと生まれてからもう殺されるかもという恐怖感で生きていなくちゃいかんですね
それって我々人間から見れば相当の苦しみなんですよ
だって私たちは殺されるかもという
あまり感じないでしょ
あの ISIS が元気で頑張っている地方以外はね
あれは神様の人々だからね
どこで誰に殺されるか分からない
誰に捕まれて首を切っちゃうとわからない
女の人は外を出たらもう何されるかわからない
自分で犯して あなたは結婚してない男と寝たからといって石を投げて殺すんだからね
女性を犯した人も石を投げるんですよ
素晴らしいでしょ だから仏教から見れば何者かとハッキリわかりますね
だから人間の形取っても
畜生と餓鬼道地獄に落ちるための準備をやっているだけなんです
あんなに怒り 嫉妬 憎しみで生命を恨んで生きていると
1 日 5回お祈りしたってもね
残念です 豚肉を食べないからといって天国には行けません
ただ 人間食べる料理はほとんど食べられないだけなんです
はい 畜生の苦しみっていうのは餓鬼道ほど強くないんだけど
この恐怖感 並みじゃないんです
海の魚たち 水の魚で考えてください
平和でいる わからない
誰かかけてバクッてやっちゃうんだからね
人間界になってくると
空楽 不空楽が回転します
人間界っていうのはあんまり中途半端なんですよ
人間に生まれてよかったと言って
いいづらいんですよ いろんな苦労があったんだから
あるんだから じゃあ人間ってあんた本当に苦しいですか？と
そうでもない いろいろ楽しみもありますね
中途半端ですよ 人間というのは
とにかく人間次元では空楽
不空 不楽が回転するんです
だから地獄 餓鬼道 畜生とは大違いいます
向こうは空世界 空の世界なんです
しかし 個人個人の空楽
不空楽の回転は互いに違います
では 人間の世界で一人一人
すべての人間が同じ量の空楽
不空 不楽を感じるかというと
そうじゃないでしょ 個人個人のプログラムが違うんです
数字で言えばもうね 例えば 3.2 とか 4 とかね
こんなあれで割り当てで変わると
それはわかりません 一人一人が違います
であるならば すべての生命の場合は
この回転のサイクルが違うんです
例えば犬の畜生 犬の次元があるでしょ？すべての犬が同じく苦楽を感じる
そうじゃないんですね
それぞれ違います はい
天界は楽を回転する 天界という次元の場合は
この人間界と違って楽が回転しているんですね
それから天界の神々 個人個人で回転する楽のサイクルが違うんです
まあ一応仏典を物語みたいな感じで書いてますから
まあ読んでみていたら
いろいろ神々の世界はどうなっているのかどうかね
で それぞれの楽しみ方が違うんです
しかし この神々の次元の共通点は
みんな体を持っているんですね
あの体っていうのは この遺伝子でできて細胞やと思っちゃうと
それは勘違いもいいところで
物質っていう意味なんですね
だから地球外生命を探している科学者は
地球にいると同じく遺伝子で細胞でできている生命を探しているんです
地球と同じ環境であるならばいるかも
例えば火星に生命がいるとするならば
まるっきり我々の体と違うでしょ
そうすると 我々の科学知識では生命体として認識することはできません
私は火星に行ったことがないんだから
生命がいるかどうかはわかりませんが
あの一応あの体といったら
この細胞でできている体だと思わないでください
物質エネルギーが心と一緒になって働いていますね
そこで神々はこの体から楽を得ているんです
それで神々が苦しみを感じちゃうと
その瞬間で死ぬんです
あの体はもう持たないんです
楽を感じるならば もう物質組織が維持管理できるんです
ちょっとでも何かにぶつけて痛くなったら
その神が死ぬんです 痛みっていうのは苦でしょ？だから神々の体は何にもぶつからないようにできているんです
我々の物質知識から見れば
例えばニューロンでニューロンじゃない何でしたっけ？ニュートリノで体ができていると思ったら
地球は通っていけるでしょ？壁なんかぶつからないでしょ？ニュートリノだから
その例えで これはその通りじゃないんだけど
例えで理解してください
だから神々はまあ何かに当たったりすることはないんですね
当たっちゃうと苦が生まれる可能性はありますね
しかし 神々の間で体ぶつかったりはします
そうすると楽しみが生まれるんです
例えば人間もそうでしょう
それなりのお互い抱き合ったりしているでしょ
あれって楽しみが生まれるでしょ
だから人を抱くと気持ちいいんだったら
ぎゅーっと抱いてみてください
力強く苦しくなるんですね
息ができなくて だから人間同士も互いに抱き合ったり
接近したりはしますね
その場合は 我々は楽しみ感じる程度で見事に調整しているんです
そういうわけで 神々は素晴らしいじゃないんで
一概に 彼らにもものすごいリミットがあるんです
梵天は体に頼らず精神の清す安楽を感じるんです
梵天という次元というのは
もう体あるんですね ある梵天とない梵天がいるんです
体あるんだけど 体関係ないんです
ただ心の住所だけですね
体は で 私たちも住所を持ってるでしょ？でもその場所今いないでしょ？だからそんな感じで
精神心だけすごく清す感
安穏を感じるんです それにまたたくさん次元があります
梵天の次元はものすごいたくさんですよ
梵天の一番最下の次元にしても
3種類があります で それは気圧感の強弱で安穏の強弱で決めます
心が安穏でずっといるならば
この体から心に影響を与えない
体が心の波長を変えないならば
長い長い時間生きられます
だから梵天というのは
このの寿命が光で数えるんです
光っていうのは 宇宙が一つワンサイクル消えて現れる時間なんですね
それが位置で数えて それぐらい長くいられます
理由は安穏で流れる心はの流れを乱れる原因はなかなかないんですね
それでも業が決めるんだから
この寿命を 生命はだから業の力が尽きると
心が弱くなってきて 安穏の流れがちょっと乱れるんです
乱れたらそこで亡くならなくちゃいかんのです
では この話では 業は全部命を作る
地獄の命を作るか 業を作るんです
畜生の命も業が作る だから業がこじこじ個性個人個人だから生命はね
我々も個人個人でしょ
だから自分に業があって
例えば私の業が私の命を作っているんですね
今 人間という乗り物を作ったんだから
この乗り物の寿命が終わったらそれは壊れる
そうすると次に業のエネルギーで次の身体を作ったりする
次の乗り物 なんか業が全知全能のように感じますね
でも 業にも絶対的な力がないんですね
因縁により現れるものですね
業も因果法則で機能しなくちゃあかんのです
はい 業のリミット 業は心が持つ力の一つですね
心のその他の力によって
業が強くなったり弱くなったりします
業っていうのは心のエネルギーの一つですから
エネルギーは心の他のエネルギーと組み合わせて仕事をしなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば上手に文字が書ける
美しい文字が書ける人がいるとしましょう
その人はすごく立派な品質の良い万年筆かボールペンを持っている
高いもの いいもの じゃあ書ける？書けない
やっぱり紙が必要ですよ
では 紙と腕に能力ある高価なボールペンは持っている
書けるかと 書けません
その紙を手の上にやってたら書けませんね
それは何かの台に置いて
机の上に置いて固定してもらったら
抜群に美しい字を書けるんですね
だから自分には美しい文字を書けるという能力があったからといって
そう簡単にその力を発揮することはできません
他の条件も揃ってこなくちゃいけないんですね
これは因果法則という世界なんです
心は常に新しい業を作って蓄えます
それで心っていうのは全体的にまとめて心というんですね
エネルギーの塊に エネルギーのいろいろ組織にまとめて心というんです
それで心がいつでも新しい業を作るんで
新しいポテンシャルを作る
作って蓄える 作って蓄える
これは終わらないんです
だからこの死後 心配 修養かしないか関係なく
死んだらまた命が現れます
いくらでもポテンシャルがあるんです
だって瞬間瞬間 我々は業を作って
業というのはポテンシャルを作って蓄える
ポテンシャルを作って蓄える
業に力があっても 心の他の条件が揃わないと結果は出ません
例えば 業がものすごく綺麗な声を出せる声帯を作る
体 業が作るんだからね
ある人間が生まれて大きくなると
声帯システムが抜群 しかしすごい有名な歌手になる
それは他の条件そろってこないとね
最初のお母さん お父さんがすごくびっくりして応援してあげて
あるいはいろいろ塾に通わせてあげたりしないとね
それからそれなりのプロに紹介してあげて
何とかしないとね 例えば日本でそういう素晴らしい声帯システムを持っている子供が生まれる
アメリカでも生まれる
どちらの方が世界的に知られる？アメリカの方でしょ
日本ではそれなりの歌手になって
それで食べているでしょうね
アメリカの子供はものすごくいきなりもう成長しちゃって
もう世界に知られてしまうんですね
それって二人との業同じかも
同じですけど 他の 原因で結果が出るんです
だから同じ業であっても勝手に活動することはできません
生命を創生する力をなくすことも心にできます
しかし 心にもう一つできるんです
この業を強くすることもできるし
弱くすることもできるし
業の力をチャラにすることもできます
だから 業自体は全知全能じゃないんですね
次は感情というテーマで理解しておきましょう
仏教では煩悩と言いますね
感情にはね この心の特色は
業を管理したり変えたり
強弱無効にしたりします
この感情というエネルギーが業をいじるんです
業が命を作っているんだけど
やっぱりやられますね
感情によって 感情の中に悪
善 中立 3種類あります
悪感情 善感情 中立感情という 3種類あるんです
中立は一緒に一緒に働く
善によって善になり 悪によって悪になります
だから中立の感情が仲間の色に染めてしまいます
悪感情が悪業 善感情は善業を作ります
この悪業を善業にしているのは
与える感覚 苦楽 不苦不楽の結果を出せることからね
苦の結果出すならば悪業というんです
楽と不苦不楽の感覚が生まれるならば
それは善業というんです
次 環境という言葉を勉強しましょう
業が体を作るんです その体が物質の法則と環境という条件の中で活動しなくてはいけないんです
業が体を作るんだけど
例えば人間に生まれる場合はわかりやすいんだから
単細胞で生まれるんですよ
だから両親のどんな遺伝子で組み合わせるのかということは
業が決めるんです 母親も父親も膨大なバイオデータを持っているんです
もうものすごいむしろの過去からのバイオデータを持っていますよ
しかし おなかの中で生命が誕生すると
母親の遺伝子からある一部取って
父親からある一部取って
単細胞 1個になるんですね
それで業が絡み合って
これこれに合わせましょうということになるんです
だから それからその細胞はどんなふうな人間に成長するのかということは
業というよりも普通の遺伝子の法則で起こるんです
例えば細胞分裂する過程で
もしかすると目の組織が現れない
いろいろあります これはこの命が誕生した瞬間で
業がもう決めてしまっちゃったんですね
しかし 業にどこまで頑張れるかというと
そこはちょっと問題で
体を作ったら物質ですからね
物質は物質の法則を使ったりする
環境もありますね 我々はそうやって
例えば今暑いだからね
例えばどなたかね すごい幸福で生きられる業を持っているかもしれませんだけど
でも外に入ったら暑くてたまらんです
苦を感じちゃうんです
業のプログラムは この人に楽を感じさせたいなんですが
環境で負けちゃうんです
だから寿命が長い人が
例えば戦闘が起きているそういう戦地帯に行ったら
流れ弾にやられる可能性あります
それで環境で命が危うい状態になるということはありますね
業の勝手で結果を出すことはできません
業の存在を直接認識することはできます
それから じゃあそこまで業が我々を支配しているんだったら
業ってなんでわからないのかと
仏教で業の話いっぱい言うんだけど
よくわからないね 業があるかないかも
発見できます 私 今思い出した例を言いますね
例えば 日本で一番力強い人は総理大臣なんです
憲法を動かして国を維持管理するのは
職務的には総理大臣のすべて仕事なんです
しかし 勝手に仕事できる？できない
まず憲法に従わなくちゃいけない
憲法ってただのアイデアの流れだけでね
それからいろんな人の意見と合わせなくちゃいけない
あらゆる煙を回らなくちゃいけない
だから本当に力あるのかいっていうことになってくるでしょ
そんな感じで 一旦すごい力持ちのように
権力持ちのように見えるんだけど
それはそんなに自由に実行できません
裁判官の人は処刑というふうに決める権利がありますよ
人を殺す指令出すんですよ
でも勝手にできますかね
だから裁判官が人死刑と決めたら
その裁判官には何の罪もないんです
彼が給料もらって楽しく生活できる
それで裁判官に個人的な嫌な人がいる
あるいは自分の奥さんにちょっかい出した人とかいるとかね
じゃあ何十を死刑に決めるとできる？できない
やっぱり条件の中で力発揮しなくちゃいけないんですね
はい 次から業はどうやって認識するのかと
しかし この苦楽不苦楽の流れを観察すると
業という衝動が潜んでいることを発見できます
だから 我々一般人がどうやって業を理解するのかというより
自分の人生をね 客観的にどれぐらい楽しかったか
どれぐらい不幸にあったか
どれぐらい悲しいことに出会ったかとかね
そこをじっと見てデータ取ってみると
あるパターンが見えてくるんですね
ある割り当てが見えてくるんです
例えば 学校でいじめられた子は
会社に入ってもなんかみんなにあまりよろしく思われてこないということもあり得る
皆さんもよく知っているところで
一回離婚したら また二度でも離婚しちゃうということが一般的な例でしょう
なんかパターンがあるんですね
だから個人が自分の苦楽
不苦不楽のどんなサイクルで回っているのかと理解したら
これは自分の業なんです
もう一つ 業のことを発見できない理由が
この心のリミットなんですね
心に外から対象が入らないと認識することはできないんです
だから我々を教える瞑想法によって
自分の心に現れる怒り
嫉妬 落ち込みなども客観的に見ることができますけど
一般世界ではそれはできないんですね
怒って反応するだけで
自分が怒っていることに気づかないんです
だから この概念とこういう派手な感情なんかは認識できます
それ以外 あの業のエネルギーが認識対象にならないんですね
だから 業の発見は創覚者であるブッダにしかできないことなんです
でも 我々にはなんとなく自分のサイクルを発見できます
はい 次 別なテーマに行きます
業を作ったり変えたりする力
これは意志チェータナ
新たな業を作ります チェータナは中立です
あの 感情のリストの中でね
チェータナというと この意志という風に日本訳するんですね
心の貪瞋痴と不貪不瞋不痴によって
チェータナが悪になったり
善になったりします それで悟りに達した人にもチェータナ意志があります
しかし 貪瞋痴がない 貪瞋痴がなくなっちゃうと
比較的に現れる不貪不瞋不痴もない
そうすると中立でいられるんです
人はチェータナを発見して管理するならば
業の管理 幸福の管理ですね
したことになります だから我々は自分の意志を発見しなくちゃいけない
ちょっと頑張らなくちゃいけない
だからこの仏教の修行とは至って簡単なことなんですよ
自分の心にある怒りを発見してみる
落ち込みを発見してみる
欲を発見してみる そうやっていると
意志というものも発見できます
意志っていうのは このやる気みたいなもんですよ
至って簡単です やる気そのものは中立です
しかし 何をやりたかったのかということで
善になったり悪になったりする
それは貪瞋痴が決めるんです
そこでこの意志の管理ですよ
人間に一番大事なのは
意志を管理すれば もう自由自在に生きられます
意志は自由であるという誤解もあるが
意志も因縁法則に従うものです
あの生命に自由はないんです
すべて因縁法則なんです
だから人の意志だからね
これは英語で willと言いますね
英語でよくあるフレーズとフリー will 自由意志
ただ言葉だけ自由意志は存在しないんです
例えばやる気がない人がいるということは
意志が弱いでしょ？強くしたい
強くしたければ はい 強くなったとできませんね
やる気がなくて落ち込んでいる人は
瞬間にやる気が起きましたと
これはありえないんです
何かいろいろからくりをして
やる気を引き起こさなくちゃいけないんです
仕事をする時でも やる気がなんか落ち込んでくる
そうすると仕事をやめてジョギングでもしてみるとかね
ボキンでして すごく体を動かしちゃってなってくると
またやる気が起きているかもね
そういう風に因果法則に従って意志を
やる気を作ったりしなくちゃいけないんですね
だから意志っていうものも自由じゃないんです
因縁に合わせて意志を変えるものですね
はい これで今日のテーマに入りましょう
人間界の特権 チェタナを自由に管理することが特権としてできる
人間特権がチェタナ 意志を自由に変えられます
犬にはできません カラスにできません
神々にもできません これすごいことなんですよ
意志を変えたとは 業を変えることなんです
要するに 業が決めたプログラムを改悪
改良することができるんです
意志で 業が貧乏で生まれるように作った体を
意志の管理ですごい億万長者に生きることもできます
業が病弱の体を作っても
意志を使って健康な体を作ることはできます
だから業をバイパスできませんだけど
業をメンテナンスすることと
それなりに変えることができますね
これは人間界次元の特権なんです
犬猫にできません 魚たちにできません
でもみんな意志持ってます
でも極力リミットされています
我々人間が神様たちは偉いと思っている固定概念があるんだけど
彼らに自由がないんです
自由自在に何もできません
これ我々に理解するためにあるエピソードがあります
これはスリランカのでできたエピソードで
どこまで本当か私はわかりませんだけど
スリランカ歴史ではかなり昔
一番最初のピリオドでね
18年間ぐらいすごい乾季
雨が降らなかったんですね
だからこれ大変で 食べ物も何もなくなって
ものすごい危険な状態で
お坊さんたちも生活できなくてインドに逃げたんですね
しかし 若いお坊さんたちをインドに送りましたけど
すごい年取ったお坊さんたちはいいやっていうことで待っていて
あるお坊さんがあの 人間の村にいると殺されるかも
食べるものないんだけど
お坊さん見るとあらかたしますよ
当然それで人間でも見つけたら殺して食べるぐらいの食料はなかったみたい
だからこの立派なお坊さんたちは
だから人間に顔を見せない方がいいんじゃないかと
森でいて 森にいたっても戒律を完璧に守ると
だから自分で葉っぱとか何とか取っては食べないんです
そのある木の上で ある神がいてね
木に宿っていた こんな立派なお坊さんがね
こんなに完璧に戒律を守っていたのに
何かお布施したら 素晴らしいことでしょうと
でも自分には神なのに
何か食べ物を持ってあげることはできないんです
それで彼がこう考えるんですね
彼か彼女かよくわかりませんだけど
このお坊さんの業はどうなっているのかと
見たら このお坊さんの過去でまた修行していて
ご飯を食べたんですね
ご飯を食べて終わって
全部もう鉢も洗って終わったら
お腹が空いている野良犬が来たそうです
お坊さんがこの犬はお腹が空いていて飢えているんだ
かわいそう もう私は食べたんだから
私のご飯をあげればいいのにとか
よかったのにと どうしようかと
まあ仕方がない 言って
喉に指を入れて食べたものはもう吐いたんです
吐いて犬に食べさせたんです
これ 素晴らしい行為なんですね
あ この業を使えるんだと
このお坊さんに 言って
神様があの業の力で何か食べ物が現れた方がいいと言ったら
神のところでご飯現れるんだそうです
それでお布施してお坊さん
これ食べて生活してくださいとということになったそうです
どこまで本当の話かどうかはわかりませんだけど
私は異議とするポイントはわかります
1 神々は偉いところにいるかもしれませんけど
我々よりは自由がないんです
あんなに完璧 立派な聖者にさえ
何かお布施することはできないんです
皆様お願いしたっても
もう話にならんでしょ
心汚れてる方々は あれこれこれこれと言ったってもできない
それでそのお坊さんが普通のノーマルな食べ物をいただいたんです
それはそのお坊さんの業の結果なんです
あの神が環境だけ作ってあげたんです
だから そういう物語で理解すると
なんとなくこの複雑な世界はわかりやすいんですよ
環境を作ると あの業が発揮しますよ
例えば自分に子供が生まれる
ものすごい自由で いろんなことを調べて
自分で発見したいというすごい能力がある
頭も良くて それでお母さんがこの子は日本でね
決まりにこだわって 厳しいこだわっている
この機械的な世界では
この子は潰れますよとと思う
天才的な能力があるのに
これは日本の教育システムでは壊す
大体天才的な能力がある子供だったら自殺して終わっちゃうんです
中学で 日本の社会では育ちません
そのお母さん 子供のことをよく知って
やっぱりこの子 自分生きたいように大成功を収めてほしいと思っちゃったら
お母さんできることは環境を変えてあげる
なんとかして自分の力で頑張れる
アメリカみたいなヨーロッパどこかに
なんとかコネを作ってそこら辺に送ることなんです
人の養子に出したってもいいんです
ヨーロッパのどこかの家族が養子にもらったら
若い子だから育てるでしょ
そうすると 自分生まれつき持ってきて能力がいくらでも発揮できる
だからその場合は お母さんに子供を幸せにしてあげることはできませんね
お母さんにできることが
業が発揮できるように環境を変えてあげることなんですね
そのように環境下で 私は仏教の世界でも結構いろんなこと知ってますよ
みんなにそれを全部言ってないんです
これ 日本環境で言える範囲のものは言ってるんです
私は自分の国で説法するならば
最近やめたんだけど その環境で理解できる仏教しか喋れません
もし私のアメリカ人に喋ったならば
このテーマはまるっきり変わっちゃうんです
別な方向に 同じテーマであっても
そういうことで この 環境によって結果が出るということをね
理解してください 神々でさえ
業が与えた条件の中で生きていなくてはならないんです
人間界では生きるために思考能力が必要です
これ よくわかりやすいんですよ
人間だけ思考しなきゃ生きていられないんです
ヘビは学校に行く必要ないんです
ヘビで生まれたらもうネズミ
カエルなどなどを食べる能力を持っているんです
カラスは学校に行く必要ないんです
空で生まれたらもう何を食べて
どんな風に巣を作って
どのように子育てすればいいかと
もう知っているんです
思考しないでできる それは業のからくりなんです
しかし 人間が学校に行かなかったらどうにもならんでしょ
物事を考えて判断しなきゃどうにもならんでしょ
面白い例あるでしょ だから犬は何を食べたいの？食べるものなるのかよく知っている
犬にパイナップル切ってあげたっても食べませんね
パパイヤ食べる犬はいますけどね
日本でいるかどうかはわかりませんだけどね
で スリランカのどこかのお寺で
普通捨て犬ですけど 犬がいて
なんかネットでも出ましたね
犬の話が なぜかというと
菜食主義なんですね ご飯と野菜のカレーだったら食べるんだけど
肉 魚 干し魚食べません
出しても これは変でしょ
それでカラスは何食べるべきか
何を食べられないかよく知っている
人間になってくるとどうですかね
知らないんですよ これは食べるべき
これは食べてはいけないとかね
知らないんだから 我々それ知識で
先人たちの能力で学ぶんです
それから料理もしたりするでしょ
知識なければ料理できないでしょ
それで料理を作る場合でも
いろいろ体に これだったらいい
これだったら悪いとかね
考えて料理作ったりする
あなたは糖尿病ですから
じゃあ料理はこういう風に作りましょうと
この子の料理にしましょうとかね
あなたは今スポーツやってるんだから
じゃあこういう料理でいいんでしょうとかね
全て知識の世界なんです
本能の世界じゃないんです
動物が持っている本能は使ってないんです
我々は本能の機能を極力低下させて知識を使っているんです
これが人間の次元だけなんです
思考能力 思考能力自体がそんなに威張る能力じゃないんですよ
あれはこの業が与えた人間という肉体を維持するために必要だから
業がお前は自分で考えて生きてなさいと指令しているんです
自分で判断して 自分で考えて生きてみなさいと
それに必要な思考能力を上げるんですね
それでバラバラわかるでしょ
バラバラであることは
思考能力がなくて 大した仕事もできなくて
大した収入もなくて苦労する人もいるしね
立派な思考能力と判断能力があって
社員に入ったところで
まあ 8年  10年  9年になってくると
もう社長まで上っている人もいるでしょ
だから思考能力が業が与えてくれたんです
それを使って生きてみるんですね
人間が 思考次第で幸福になったり
不幸になったりします
思考は心の管轄です 思考って心でやってるでしょ？チェタナの心の特色です
思考するためにチェタナが必要で
思考したい 考えたい 判断したい
というチェタナが必要です
美味しいものを食いたいと気持ちが起きても
じゃあ今日は何食べれば美味しく感じるのかと
私はあまりいろいろ名前を知らんんだけど
肉じゃがという名前を覚えているんですね
今日は肉じゃがを食べた方が美味しいねと
それでチェタナがじゃあ肉じゃが作るんだったら
これとこれと玉ねぎやじゃがいもやら肉とかね
まあこういう 味付けはこれこれとかね
それで考えて 順番で因果法則に沿って肉じゃがを作る
そこで食べて ああ 美味しかったってあれになる
だから思考するために意志チェタナが必要です
これが一番いいことですよ
チェタナはつかめ つかめますから
だから考える能力あるんだから
だったらチェタナを管理する能力もあるんです
人間に 思考するために変えるためにチェタナが必要です
はい では奇跡って何なのかと
奇跡ってそれなんですよ
プログラム変えてみせる
貧困で生まれる運命なんですけど
億万長者で終わらせてみせる
教育システム全くないところで生まれても
思考とチェタナ変えてすごい世界的に知られている知識人になることも可能です
だから この可能な範囲はものすごい広いんです
例えば人間が飛べないでしょ？でも人間思考するんだから飛べればいいなと思ったんです
思考したんです 今飛んでるでしょ？だから奇跡というのはそういうことなんです
自然法則ならあり得ない
不可能なことはあり得るようにする
可能にする だから人間には不可能可能にする特権を持ってるんです
それ使ってほしいんです
チェタナと思考能力を正しく使えば
人は希望通りに生きることができるのです
他の次元の生命にはこの自由はありません
人間が誇る科学発展と文明は
長い間 チェタナと思考能力を駆使した結果です
これからも人間の世界が変わっていくんです
人間がチェタナと思考を使っているんです
だからもう世界が毎日変わっていくんです
しかし 因縁法則は変えませんね
これはもう法則です 思考チェータナ使う時でも
因縁のことをよく理解してやらなくちゃいけない
はい そういうところで半分ぐらい行きましたので
ちょっと休憩いたします
はい だいたい揃ったんですから始めます
後半は大事です 人間の過ち
業が与えた自由を悪用しています
この奇跡能力あるのに悪用しているんですね
一番無知に負ける 生まれたら感情のままで生きようとする
物質を勉強するが 支配者である心について学べない
我々は学校で物質の勉強をします
心の勉強はしません 我輩は何でも知っているという調子で生きているんです
感情をかき回すことが生きる目的と生きがいになっている
我々は感情をかき回すために生きているんですね
なんだこりゃと 生きがいっていうのは感情なんです
例えば子供が生きがいといったら
子供から生まれるあの感情なんですよ
生きがいになっているのは
先入観を一切使わず 物事を客観的に調べて正しい知識を得る努力はしていない
我々は何か知る場合は
必ず先入観で知っているんです
必ず固定概念を使うんです
必ず 私は日本で説法を始めたら
日本の文化と日本の価値観に合わせて喋ってくださいと
ああ そうという感じで
私は ということは 仏教じゃなくて
なんかインチキ仏教を喋らなくちゃあかんでしょう
本物を喋れないんです
私は聞いてないんだけど
の話は これが無知に負けたことですね
それから信仰と迷信 調べたくはない
調べられない場合は 無知は信仰に変身して知ってるつもりを作る
人類そうでしょ 調べたくはないものがある
調べても調べられないものもある
それで信仰で補います
例えば 生命が 生命の肉体が進化したんだということは知らなかったんですね
では神が創ったと はい
終わり それで調べられる人々は命かけて調べたんです
殺されるぐらい怖かったんです
で 今は肉体の進化は知っているが
いまだに心を なことは知らないんですね
努力して得るべきものを迷信に頼って得ようとする
例えば金持ちになりたいといったら頑張れでしょう
答えはいいえ 何か財産に与えてくれる何か恵みの神が神がいるんだったらね
そちらに行って拝みましょうと
商売繁盛の神様 それは学問の神様がいるんですよ
日本で なんでああいう迷信が現れるかというと
こいつら怠け者なんですね
でも学問の神様にお願いしたからといって
学識得ることは一瞬もないんです
結局自分が努力した分だけなんですね
そうやって努力して得るべきものが怠けて迷信で得ようとする
占いで得ようとする 勝手な決まりを無数に作って
自分で自分を縛る 何も意味も訳もわからない決まりがあるわあるわあるわ
何なのかわからない だから何やとわからない
お嫁さんが何か素の隠しという白い布を頭にかぶっちゃうでしょ
何なのかと でもこれでかっこいいというならば
私は OK なんです これつけたらかっこいいよ
美しいやと言いならば OK なんですけど
くっつけらない決まり
何やとわからない決まりがいっぱいあって
我々すごく縛られているんですね
これ人間作ったんだからね
先入先人たちのにかぶせた知識と能力を無批判的に使うから
自分の特有の力 意思を後の発見しません
我々は知識人だと思っているんだけど
あれはかぶせたものです
先人たちに だから自分の能力を発見しない
思考の代わりに妄想を選ぶ
これすごい問題なんです
感情をかき立てる が 生きるもかき立てることがですね
生きる目的になっているんですね
ちょっと文章言葉が一つ抜けてます
感情をかき立てることが生きる目的になっているんです
感情の刺激で妄想し始める
感情が この場合 必ず悪感情でしょ
悪感情の刺激で妄想を始めるんです
だから妄想するときも
思考するときでも 心の同じエネルギーを使わなくちゃあかんでしょ
だからすごく必要不可欠
必要な思考ができなくなるんです
もうエネルギー使って使い切っているんですと
思考する場合は客観的なデータを使わなくてはいけないんです
だから楽ではありません
飛行機を開発したことが楽ではなかったんですよ
あれ 思考の結果なんです
妄想は感情だけで十分ですから
思考をやめて妄想するんです
こんな危険な怖いことをやっていいのかと
だって妄想するために何もデータはいらんだからね
何もいらん 感情だけで十分
悪感情だけで これでものすごい奇跡を起せる能力を持って人間になったのに
何一つするもできない
威張って神のしもべであるとか
そんな程度まで落ちるんです
人間が それで奇跡の力が消えたんです
はい 皆様も仏教はなんであるかともうわかっているでしょう
仏教はその道を教えているんです
奇跡を起こす道を 感情をコントロールする道を
チェータナーをしっかり握れる道を
はい 人間に生まれたならば
人間にしかできない能力に挑戦します
このチャンス逃してはならんです
感 1 感情の制御 これやらなくちゃあかんです
悪感情 善感情をまず区別する
これ一人一人でやらなくちゃいけないんです
悪感情を控えて善感情を育てる努力
だからみんなにもあるでしょう
いいところも悪いところも
それはちゃんと調べてみる
私のいいところはこれこれ
悪いところはこれこれと
それで悪いところはちょっと後回しにしましょうと
いいところはどんどん使いましょうと
貪瞋痴の感情を暴走しないようにする
誰にだって貪瞋痴があります
悟らない限りは これは危険なエネルギーで悪感情です
これは暴走しないように制御しておくんです
考える 話す 行動する その時
悪感情を使いません 今
本当に今 私はこの八正道を説明しているんです
仏教の 我々考えてるでしょ？考える時は感情を使いません
喋るでしょ 喋る時は貪瞋痴の感情で喋りません
いろいろ料理作ったり
洗濯したり 仕事したりするで
体が動かなくて その時も貪瞋痴の悪感情は使いませんと使いませんと決めた方がいいでしょう
怠け者は信仰迷信に頼るが
正しく生きる人間であるならば
心を先入観とマインドコントロールから解放することに励む
信仰と迷信というのは怠け者の世界なんですね
人間を諦めた世界なんです
私たちは先入観なくそう
マインドコントロールをなんとかなくそうということで努力すれば
それから思いやり 慈しみ
これも人間にしかできないんです
神々も自分のことで精いっぱいです
だからわがままですよ
でも文句言えない それしか能力ないんだから
皆様 飼っている猫が我々の気持ちを考えたりすることをしますか？しない
自分わがままです でも仕方がないでしょ
我々は猫に怒らないでしょ
このわがままなやつやとかね
言わないね 知ってます
しかし 私たちに子供がわがまま言うと
わがまま言うなよと子供にまで言うんだからね
これは人間の特権なんですよ
思いやりと慈しみは 業がこの維持管理しかしないんです
業っていうのは この個っていうのは作った体の維持管理するん
それ以外能力を持っていないんです
業にも そこでですから
他の生命に対して思いやり
慈しみを努力して実行しなくちゃいけないんです
これは奇跡的なんです
業に任せちゃうと わがままで終わっちゃうんです
そこで我々は業をちょっと抑えて
他の生命を慈しんでみるんです
思いやりを実践してみるんです
すべての生命は 自我中心的ですが
人間はこれ変えることができます
これは人間にしかできない奇跡なんです
奇跡なんです 自我中心を変えられます
見解を正見に変える 思考妄想するために見解
見解というのは偏見なんですね
必要です この偏見というのは専門用語で
ある側面でしか見えないというね
例えばカラスが死んだネズミの死骸を見ると
偏見を持っちゃう ごちそうやと
人間がネズミの死骸を見ると
偏見を持って気持ち悪いと
どちらでも偏見なんです
で だから考えるために我々には偏見が必要です
自分という錯覚を前提にして物事を認識すると
現れるのは見解 偏見です
だから自分という人間という錯覚でネズミの死骸を見ると気持ち悪いですよ
じゃあ人間というあれ
ちょっと捨ててみたら
ネズミの死骸です カラスにとってはごちそう
放っておけば悪臭になる
人間にとっては健康には良くないものでと
で 肉体を持ってる生命だから
心が抜けたらそうやって腐敗していく
この体も同じですと そうすると偏見がないんです
そのままデータ見ただけです
気持ち悪いとかね ごちそうとか
それは出てこない 客観的に自分の好みを入れず
物事を判断するようにしましょう
これは一種の修行なんですよ
これ 気をつけてください
我々に人間という偏見があるんです
あるんだけど 偏見ないようにも見ようとする
見解は変化しますが 事実に基づいた認識は変わらないという法則で法則を覚えて
見解を正見に変える努力をします
だからこの法則があります
法則は見解はいつでも変わっちゃうんです
今日言ったことは 明日になってくると嘘になるんです
今日発見した科学事実
事実は明日になってくると間違っているとなるんです
見解はいつでももう立場がない
もう変わるんです しかし
真理は変わらない 正見なら変わらないと思って
この変わらないものを発見しようと
例えばネズミの死骸は気持ち悪いではなく
肉体を持っている生命
誰であっても死んだら同じことになるんだ
犬が死んでも 猫が死んでも
クマさんが死んでも ネズミが死んだっても
自分が死んでも 同じ物体が同じく壊れていくんだと
それはカラスなどの生命の食べ物ですよと
人間が死んだら今はもったいないんだけど
昔なら死骸は全部他の生命は食べ物にするんですよ
だから 人間が獣たちが住んでいる山で死んじゃったら
きれいに食べてくれるんです
骨だけ残って だから そういうふうに物事を見たら
それは変わらないでしょう
事実は 心の働きを学ぶ
次のレッスンは 心はどのように働くのかよと学んでみましょう
心という組織を発見する
まず心を発見します これはヴィパッサナー瞑想で一番最初に出てくる宿題なんです
実況中継していると 物体と感情の組織
別々に見えてくるんです
業が輪廻転生を作る理由を発見する
それは渇愛なんです なんで私は輪廻転生するんですかと
それでわかります 自分が生きていきたいんですね
その気持ちが変です なぜならば生命は死ぬのに
それで偏見で死ぬ事実を無視して
死にたくないというとんでもないことを入れちゃうんです
それは渇愛というんです
この誤解 あ これが問題だと発見してほしい
ありのままに生きることを観察する
だからそれにありのままの命を観察するんです
そうすると渇愛を発見できるんです
ありのままに 洗濯したり
料理作ったり それは観察してやるんです
そうすると 洗濯するときでも
生きていきたいからやっていることである
料理を作るときでも 生きていきたいからやっていることやと
歯を磨くときでも 生きて生きていきたいからやっていることやと
いつでも渇愛が割り込んでいることを見えてくるんです
はい  ありのままに生きること
ありのままに点が入る
ん？ ありのままに生きることを
うん あるがままに点ですね
え？ そのまま続けてしまうと
ありのままに生きていることを
はいはいはい わかりました
ありのままにという点を入れてください
それは間違いですね あるいは生きることをありのままに観察する
場所を１個すれば直ります
今時間ないんだからね
もうちょっとさっさと飛ばします
現象の無常苦無我を発見する
それに智慧というんです
これは真理です 変わりません
一切の現象は無常です
心も無常です 物質も無常です
実体はありません 知識が智慧に変わると
チェタナの力で渇愛が消えるんです
業が消えるじゃなくて
渇愛が消えるんです あんなヘンテコリンな感が感情が生きていきたい
生きていきたいと 放っておけと
そんなのは ということで
チェタナでこれは放っておくちゃうんです
過去の業はそのままですが
業の再生する力がなくなります
渇愛が消えたら 業に人が死んだら新しい
また車乗り物を作ろうということもできなくなるんです
このエネルギーはもうなくなっているんです
業はあるんです 過去の業が
でも一つの能力がなくなっている
新しい命を構成するエネルギーだけ消えちゃったんです
これはチェタナで来るんですよ
意志で 意志は自由は人間だけです
だから解脱に達せますよ
人間が 今私は解脱のことを知って説明したんです
人間で生まれたならば
人格向上しなくてはいけません
感情の奴隷で生きることは畜生の次元です
だからせっかく畜生をやめましょう
他の生命の役に立つ人間にならなくてはいけません
悪感情を取り除く 取り除かなくてはいけません
人間だから 人間で生まれても
死ぬ時は生命次元を超越した聖者にならなくてはいけません
人間で生まれても 人間で死んではいけません
人間を超えて死んでほしいです
この道をできるだけ歩みましょう
ゴールまで行かなくても
できるだけ進めば ゴールは次の命を作ってくれますからね
そこでそこから走れます
それで後書きがありまして
後書きで話は終了します
生きることが宿題という
生命と生きる環境を業が作る
だから肉体という乗り物を作ってくるですし
肉体はある環境で作るんですね
皆様の肉体は日本という環境で作ったんです
他の国で生まれた人は
その環境で生きていなくちゃあかんのです
それは業がやってくれるんです
幸不幸 悩み 苦しみ 楽しみなどが回転する
人間に生まれたら アメリカ人であろうか
日本人であろうか 中国人であろうか
関係なく幸福は回転する
苦楽 不苦楽は回転する
悩み苦しみは回転する
これには民族差別はありません
一つ一つの経験は人格向上のために欠かせない宿題であると思う
これを覚えてください
皆様方は上司が悪いとかね
親のしつけが悪いとかね
こんなもうとんでもないことを文句を言うことをやめましょう
すべて宿題なんです 親が乱暴でいい加減だったら
これが宿題 それで私は何を学べるのかと
この状況では 上司が自分の悪口を言ったり
足を引っ張ったりするならば
これは宿題です 私はどうやってそれを乗り越えられるかと
結婚して間もないうちに
間違った人と結婚したと文句を言うんじゃなくて
みんなそうでしょう 間違えた相手なんだと
あ これは私の修行で宿題ですと
それに対応してみるんです
ポジティブ的に 結果は自分の人格向上にするんです
例えば私は学生の頃 子供の頃
金は一切なくて もう本は買えなかったんです
テキストは持っていなかったんです
親に買ってくれる能力はなかったんです
私は親と喧嘩しなかった
本買ってくれとか だって親も知ってますよ
子供に本を買ってあげなくちゃいけないんだと
買ってあげることできなかったらどうしますか？できないならば
私はよくわかりました
文句言いませんと なんとかしてそれは補ってみるんだと
それで私は友達を作った
友達を作って 友達とちょっとちょっと貸してとかね
隣に座ってる子供の一緒に二人でテキストを見る
それで自分で覚えて早く理解しなくちゃいけない
家でもう一度読み直すということは私にはできませんね
それで私は読んで理解することをその場でするんです
そうすると友達がすごい助かるんで
私教えてあげるんだから
だから テキスト買うお金がなかったことで
私の勉強がうまく進んだんです
いつでも試験では満点
私にとって試験というのは何か面白くない
なんだという感じで 同じことを繰り返して聞いちゃうんだからね
そんなのわかってるでしょうにという態度で書くんです
別にどうったことない
昔 我々中学卒業の国家試験ですけど
一つの科目は３時間なんです
試験の場合は 皆様に信じられないんですよ ３
時間で使わないと答えられないぐらい質問たくさんあります ３
時間かかる質問に 私には１時間半でできるんです
できたんです だからそれはなんでということは
業が宿題を与えたんです
不幸という宿題 私はじゃあ負けるかと
ということで勝ち抜いたんです
皆様にもそれぞれの宿題が業が与えているんです
だから皆様の宿題は私に関係ないんです
だから今日から人間に生まれたことは幸せであると
でもいろんなトラブルが起こる
いろんな問題が起こる
それが私の特有の宿題であると理解してください
そうすると素晴らしい人生で終わっちゃうんです
何かを学べば 悪感情にわずかでも打ち勝ったならば
宿題を正しくやったのですね
...この宿題から何が学んだら OK です
宿題から悪感情をやめて
ちょっといい人間になったならば OK
合格です 次に新たな宿題がありますよ
宿題はいつでも次から次へと来るんです
解脱に達するまで だから失敗しないこと
はい 以上です ４時半？ えー
4時半までですね はい
あと 10 分弱時間ございますけど
何かお一人かお二人か
質問ある方がいらしたらマイク出しますけど
いかがでしょうか？ちょっとあんまり目がいいので
思い切っていただいていただければ
皆さん完全に理解した
とにかく話の内容はね
結構普通一般常識では理解できないところいっぱいあったんだけど
それ忘れてもいいんだけど
この後書きのところを覚えておいてください
人生はいつでも何かしら宿題が来るものよ
自分の業が宿題くれるんです
だからいつでもそのポジティブ的にそれに当たってみて
対応してみて 何か学んでみてください
何か人格を向上してみてください
それ 今日のテーマとして覚えておいてください
はい ありがとうございます
最後の 祈願のこれ読んで終了しましょう
では ご一緒に唱えましょう
ドゥッカッパッタ チェニン ドゥンカー バヤン パッタ チェニン バヤー ソーカン パッタ チェニン ソーカー ホントゥ サンベー ピターニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい ありがとうございました
スマナサーラ先生 ありがとうございました
[拍手]